within the last week Donald Trump's ire
has turned away from Peter struck who's
been fired as we all know and it's now
focusing squarely on Bruce or Bruce or
the man whose wife worked for fusion GPS
he knew Michael Steele he'd worked with
him in the past and so that obviously
means that the entire investigation is
rigged and it is a witch-hunt right well
no because but that's what the
president's telling us Bruce or knew
Michael Steele and so therefore none of
this can be real he told us Thursday
morning that Bruce or his wife speaks
fluent Russian and therefore there's the
collusion that doesn't even make any
sense but it's how unhinged our
president has become the latest thing
that happened though with his attacks on
the FBI they came out Wednesday when he
said that Hillary Clinton's emails were
hacked and accessed by China so now he's
just moved off from Russia because at
first he was saying Hillary colluded
with Russia but now it's China's
interfering with our election we have to
do something about that and it also said
the FBI is not doing anything about it
here I mean here is tweet Hillary
Clinton's emails many of which for
classified information got hacked by
China next move better be by the FBI or
DOJ their credibility is gonna be lost
if they don't so China is now the
problem and the FBI and the DOJ don't
seem to care about Hillary Clinton
whatsoever
the FBI wasted absolutely no time firing
back at Donald Trump to explain to him
and the public that there is literally
no evidence whatsoever to suggest any of
that ever happened in fact the FBI said
there's not even any evidence to show
that anyone was ever able to access
Hillary Clinton's emails now this is not
the DNC email hack this is back to
Hillary's personal emails no evidence
whatsoever from our intelligence
agencies to show that these emails were
accessed by any one else and before all
those people out there say well that's
because they never gave them the servers
they
did they gave them access to them where
they came in and made copies of them and
then took them back and analyzed those
it was a carbon copy you can tell
everything from the copy that you could
from the original it is not common
practice in investigations state local
or federal to seize the actual computer
unless there's evidence on that machine
itself fingerprints any other kind of
thing on it otherwise they make a copy
and they take it back to headquarters
that's what they did with Hillary's
emails that's what they did with the D
and C emails so enough with that
debunked talking point but back to the
issue at hand right China
FBI Donald Trump Hillary Clinton all
some big massive collusion thing right
well as it turns out it as I said FBI
came out said this never happened but
then an interesting thing happened you
had China coming out and talking about
how egregious this statement was by the
President of the United States so not
only did he manage to once again
undermine our intelligence agencies and
the officers within the FBI he also
managed to anger another world
superpower by accusing them of hacking
someone even though there's no evidence
to ever suggest any of this Donald Trump
at this point is backed into a corner
and as I'm sure we all know you backed a
ferocious deranged rabid animal into a
corner they're gonna lash out and strike
at anything that comes their way and
that's what we're witnessing right now
with Donald Trump that is what his
Thursday morning Twitter meltdown was
all about the man was all over the place
if you haven't paid attention to his
Twitter feed from Thursday morning just
go look at how insane it was these are
not the musings are the tweets of a
rational thinking human being they're
the tweets of a madman who is losing his
grip on reality and feeling the walls
closing in on him more and more every
single day that is what is happening
with
the President of the United States and
he is becoming a major threat not just
to us here in the United States but to
everyone across the globe as he
continues to anger or in superpowers by
accusing them of things that they never
did we need to take a quick break but
you can follow me on twitter at baron
balanced you can also find me on
facebook and instagram at fair and
balanced and please you could check me
out on youtube at youtube.com slash the
Ring of Fire I am fair and cousin
sitting in for David Pakman we'll be
right back
today's program was made possible in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman i love
bling cast it's the really perfect app
for anybody who likes politics and
learning and if you're watching or
listening to the david pakman show I'm
sure you'll love politics and learning
and what blinka studs is take the best
and most popular non-fiction books they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to in one sitting
and you can learn about politics
philosophy psychology economics often we
don't have the time to actually read as
many books as we would like I know that
I'm at my limit for how much I can read
and this way you can absorb the most
important valuable information from
books in just 15 minutes maybe on your
way to work maybe on your way to the gym
maybe cooking vegan recipes at home
whatever is your thing and our audience
can get a 7 day free trial by going to
blink accom slash Pakman if you're
watching on YouTube I've put a link in
the video description and after the free
trial if you like it and I think you
will you can continue enjoying thousands
of condensed audiobooks for just about 5
bucks a month you can go to be li NK is
t.com slash PA k ma n to sign up